i don't i don't think he knows what he
means
no the way he's saying is like a stuff
what does ksi stand for it stands for
knowledge
strength strength and integrity
[Music]
guys you must must must check out my
teschia if you are suffering from bone
addiction or sex addiction visit the
site it will inshallah purify you and
inshallah is going to help you step by
step process
with full confidentiality and privacy to
get out
of this sin inshallah and get your life
back together check them out in the
description
box below
oh wow your hands are hot bro
man's a freak i'm a hot guy man's not
hot
anyways what does ksi stand for it
stands for
knowledge stan strength and integrity
wallahi ksi needs to watch this video
your name stands for what
knowledge strength integrity
with knowledge the quran comes power
as known as strength yes and for one to
live in integrity
and want to live a life of integrity
live up to your name ksi
get that quran inshallah read it open
your spectrum into the
islamic world and what god almighty has
created the heavens and earth and has
created you
once for you not only in this life but
in the hereafter
so we're going to watch this video we
need you guys every single one of you
guys are watching this this is a mission
that we're on
this is a mission preach ksi has to
watch this video
yeah how about you produce the content
you guys job is to deliver
[Laughter]
i genuinely love the way it says it
stuck like
it's it's not like you know some people
can fake it like you know like if you're
not normal
you know you can even the pronunciation
might be a bit off
this guy it's like as if he means it
like as if he knows the meaning
and he's genuinely saying it at the
right time where he's just genuinely
like
like no that shouldn't have happened you
get it i don't know it seems like he's
using in a colloquially
colloquial sense collaboration but no no
colloquia you know how people genuinely
use it yeah
when something goes wrong did i ask it
allah i think
i think me i don't i don't think he
knows what he means
no the way he's saying is like a staff
i think he's just got muslim friends
like was it a nissan gibb
and chunks yeah and they use it and
maybe they've yeah yeah he must have
picked up him he didn't say
estefan allah he's not saying it like
that that's true
and it's like you know we do something
wrong where you're like whatever it
might be like let's suppose
you you play football and you kick and
you miss
it's good because i don't know it's the
victor of allah that you have in your
tongue
but as a muslim obviously you get
rewarded but for him saying obviously
inshallah he'll come to islam but the
thing is i feel as if
it's genuine in the context of where
he's using it in the
right time the word the context of the
word that you know what that shows you
that the hadith of the process who said
that good friends and bad friends bad
friend is someone it's like
who's a blacksmith even if he doesn't
give you off you in if you're going to
leave smelling or
in you know smoke but if you have a good
friend who sells musk
even if nothing else is you're going to
leave with what's smelling good the fact
that chunks and all the other brothers
as well which i've done a video about
trunks you can check that out
the fact that it's rubbed on him in the
context where
he is left with saying you know what
stafford allah wallahi
or stuff like that bro that's big come
on bro if they're using these
terminologies etc
he might one day come and say you know
what actually what is this stuff or what
what does that mean
you know i think it's deep because it
shows you that guys
these words like benefits of good
company yes exactly
[Music]
yes so yeah pretty much i'm just on the
fence and i'm
he's on the fence um that's better than
most people who don't even
research who just follow blindly who
don't know about their faith
he's done the half of the galima
he just needs to do it exactly the thing
is
and being an agnostic it's not denying
god per se because it's basically saying
there is some kind of a power out there
i don't know yeah because you don't know
this the reason we're doing this video
so guys once again you've got to get
this video to him inshallah please
must share it to michelle if it's
possible yeah share it yeah inshallah
now let's tell him a bit about he's on
the fence why
he should maybe look into it we want ksi
to read the quran
at least yeah yeah okay saying
yeah um to understand these phrases but
most importantly
the message behind the quran and in a
nutshell
if ksi you're watching this islam
believes in the
absolute pure monotheism meaning that
the worship of one god yeah so what we
say is god is unlike his creation
yeah um and for example in christianity
they believe jesus to be divine
or a part of the god the triune god yeah
we say no
that can't be god because jesus was a
man so he can't be god because anything
that is in the creation cannot be the
creator
yeah so that's why islam we believe is a
pure monopolism because
all other religious christianity
hinduism whatever religion you
follow most of them have some kind of
idol worship be it a man be a statue so
islam calls
us human beings to the worship of one
god now we don't know your family is
christian
if i'm not mistaken yeah yeah if you are
saying you're not a christian there must
be a reason behind it yeah
but if you want to look more deep into
we've got many videos i want to bore you
you know
with going into the details and
technicalities but it's the submission
to one god and to worship him alone and
the quran is the only scripture
on this earth that hasn't been changed
and distorted and has been memorized by
millions of people
[Music]
so ksi i wanted to say one other thing
as well um
you've been through a you know a very
interesting journey you started with
fifa videos
then you played on your own stereotype
and then now you're
doing music videos and you found your
true calling
and you i mean you go anywhere you're
recognized regardless of
religion regardless of race gender or
whatever i mean you're known yeah but
only
you truly know as you're going from one
place to the other the void you feel
inside
you know there's a void yeah and you
know that you can't admit it
because you're doing all these sidemen
videos and you're doing all this stuff
on a regular basis you can't
show it to the public because you know
your popularity your views will go down
i mean look at certain
youtubers that talk about their
depression all the time
people don't like hearing about that
stuff but ksi you know you know the
reality
and i'm telling you there is an antidote
there is a depression pill
but this is not an actual pill this is
in the form of what your and my creator
has told us
yeah that if you do not remember him if
you do not acknowledge him
then your life will be void yeah it will
be filled
with depression yeah you cannot achieve
true happiness from this
yeah it's it's like a placebo and you
know you you go to the parties and you
how you make these videos and then that
walk back to
to your room or that when you wake up in
the morning or when you're in the limo
and you're looking out the window
what do you go through here what
thoughts go through your head is this
it have i achieved everything ksi the
answer is
no this is not it no the creator
mashaallah it is so there's such a
vastness that he's offered us
and we want you just like you're famous
in this world we want you to be famous
in this world
and in the hereafter as well we want
your fame to continue
not just end ahead because you know as
well as we do there's so many famous
people that have come
and they have gone yeah we do not want
you to be one of those
individuals as well by allah
exactly we want you to be trending we
want you to be famous we want you to
carry on
influencing people with righteous deeds
it's the sunnah of the prophet
sallallahu alaihi sallam to reach out to
people of influence
and that's the reason we've done this
video and a few people recommended it to
me to say to talk about it
uh and when we saw that for example that
people are asking me are you muslim
he's saying i'm not you know his
agnostic is on the floor i don't mind
allah i don't mind allah
says now i know a lot of people pick up
on like oh just because somebody said in
islamic terminology oh yeah
the point is this year and then he's a
person of influence um
and he's open to allah he said he's on
the fence he's agnostic so it's our duty
to at least
deliver the message exactly and guys and
this is what we're trying to do here
pewdiepie we've done it
and we want to go through uh these
influences and give them the message
we're gonna have different videos so the
theme of today just matches that you
know brothers and sisters we just want
to reach out to these people
get them to at least read the quran you
know and it's it's fundamental inshallah
for them and you never know one lie you
never know some people like uh
you don't know how allah works in
mysterious ways you know what i'm trying
to say
so if ksi is watching this inshallah yes
there's a lot of bad press
towards islam et cetera i personally
experience i'm a river to islam nearly
eight years
um and trust me there was every reason
for me not to pick islam in the context
of
media all these attacks that would
happen in the name of islam you know the
thing is bro
ksi he's famous as well and he knows the
amount of times the media has
misrepresented him as well exactly
and yeah he so you bro you i know we're
we're preaching to the preached like you
know how manipulative
the media can be so i mean the islam has
fallen prey
to the same thing if you you just need
to research stuff like sykes pico and
balfour declaration and
you know the berlin conference and then
you realize that there's
it's more deep rooted than oh uh groups
just
popped up yeah like even you got obama
saying yep if it wasn't for our invasion
uh in iraq isis wouldn't have popped up
and the hillary clinton you got her
saying that yes we funded al-qaeda so
even with these groups
there is it's it's there's more to
it than meets the eye yeah exactly and
inshallah
as you are saying for allah
[Music]
until next time guys get this video to
him inshallah
let's get these influences to read the
quran and
open their spectrums towards the quran
inshallah till next time assalamu
alaikum
shout
sending a bad boys to him man it might
it might end up in the news
it's nearly midnight at least
terrorizing him so next time
[Music]
on
you